welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mental podcast I'm your host
heisha mizzouz and today I'm really
excited to be joined uh by Alex Elliot
Alex thanks for joining me
that is my absolute pleasure I
understand you have um no I've listened
to you interview a couple of my
colleagues so I feel honored that it's
it's now my turn
amazing so I think where there's a few
things we're going to discuss today but
I think I always find it just to be
useful for people just to give everyone
just some context straight at the
beginning so people can understand where
you are on your journey and I guess some
of the key parts of your journey so far
so feel free to yeah add in anything
that that I've missed but since October
2019 you've joined a strive which is
yeah I've interviewed Adam I've had
other people um from strive on on the
podcast as well and and since October
2019 you've joined them as
an investor but also a strategic
director so ultimately you help those
guys scale is how you pull it to me and
I know that you're really excited about
uh the platform and the business that
um yeah you're you're helping out and
part of so we're definitely going to go
into that today and then before that
maybe what um a number of people know
you for you started
um liquid Personnel in 2006 with your
business partner John and you
successfully sold that business uh in a
private Equity deal in 2016 and the high
level stuff there is you you both
organically grew that business to 140
heads 101 million pounds in Revenue 11
million net fee income and four million
uh in ebitda so I think how we're going
to approach this is I'm going to dive
straight in with Alex on some of the the
things that he's learned in hindsight uh
looking back on his uh Journey on
building liquid personnel and then I'm
really keen and excited to then go into
uh yeah why you think you been able to
build a really great and exciting
infrastructure to strive sales and how
you've gone about that and those types
of things so um have to have to go
straight in Alex anything on this there
sounds amazing it feels like you've done
the podcast now so I don't think you
actually need me but no go ahead yeah
dive straight in
okay so I guess let I will start with
this this with this question so I'll be
Keen to get your thoughts on this I know
a big part of the business model with
liquid Personnel is you organically uh
grew that so I'd love to just hear your
take on what you believe are the sort of
characteristics and traits of a highly
successful recruitment concern in
today's market uh there may have changed
or evolved I don't know what what comes
up for you on that foreign
I think as is always the case it depends
right so it's context specific so I
think there's probably three things you
have to consider from a context
perspective perspective before you can
talk about the consistent so who you're
selling to is going to be really really
important right there's a big difference
between selling to a director of Social
Services versus selling to a VP of sales
within Tech firm so I think the the
context of who you're selling to is
really important to this question you've
also got where you're selling as well if
you're selling in the German Market
that's very different selling in the US
market so again I think you have to you
have to look at that piece of context
with regards to defining the right
profile and then lastly the stage of
growth for companies out I think is
really important as well so I think if
you're if you're selling in a in a
startup environment that business and
that model and the infrastructure around
you is going to be really really
different so if you're selling in a
large corporate environment where
basically you're handed everything and
everything's really close clear and
process Maps so if you look Beyond those
those three sort of key areas of context
which will probably give you your
differentiation between what you're
looking for the consistence and
certainly what we look at strive we look
at seven different things so
the five things that we look for from a
behavioral perspective we look for drive
we look for grits we look for
conscientiousness we look for
competitiveness and we look for
coachability so there are five things
that we believe based upon looking at
what's worked and what hasn't worked
within our particular environment
without within our particular business
we've identified those as big ticks
against people's names that if they can
demonstrate those five things
typically they're going to be really
successful
um I think it's really important how you
define those things as well so again
just on that point it's all well and
good saying we want people who are
driven but if you were to get 10
different people in a room and ask them
what their definition of Drive is you'd
probably get 10 different answers so
again I think you have to be really
clear on how you're defining those
attributes and again that's that's
business dependent
um we also you know it's slightly
differently I've heard some of your
other guests speak about things and one
thing that I never get I I haven't heard
it yet and this might be just because
I've missed it but I haven't heard it
yet we look at Gia so we look at general
intelligence and we also look at
different aspects of emotional
intelligence so as well as those five
behavioral traits we look at two
intelligence traits one general
intelligence and two there's a few key
aspects of emotional intelligence that
we look for because again if you do
regression analysis on the people who
are successful in your business you will
probably identify that there is a
benchmark within your organization where
people have to be smart enough to a
certain level
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to be a good recruiter but you do have
to be able to learn and crystallize
information pretty quickly and process
information reasonably quickly so we
also have a benchmark within our
business that we're looking for people
to achieve from a Gia perspective and on
the other side of that there's a few
particular traits within emotional
intelligence that we're looking for from
a benchmark perspective and again all of
this is is evidence-based it's not just
us plucking some some um some indicators
out of the air and saying this is what
our opinion is this is something that we
regularly review and assess to ensure
that we're being as accurate and
evidence-based as possible we forgot to
our home profile
really interesting I have to ask then
because I think maybe people will be
thinking about it what like you said
that you added there yes evidence-based
yes like talk to me a bit about that
because I think like I think like you
said you just said a lot of people are
just sort of maybe going off there got
interesting plucking out of the air when
you say evidence-based how how are you
capturing that are using different tools
or I don't know what's been the science
behind that
I don't think um early stage look you
want data points right if you want to
make evidence to base decisions you have
to have data points and early on when
you're growing a business you don't
necessarily have lots of data points now
look fortunately myself and the the
other leadership team we're pretty
experienced we've kind of done this
before this isn't our first rodeo but
for anyone who's starting out in
business even if you've had three or
four people come through your business
as trainees you're getting to a point
where you can start to identify but it's
literally sitting down and looking at
those individuals some will have been
very successful some maybe haven't been
successful and haven't worked out what
were the traits of those individuals
that were successful and what were the
traits of those people that weren't
successful or what were those people who
weren't successful what were they
missing compared to the people that
weren't successful that's your starting
point of that hypothesis right well you
know Sarah was driven whereas John
didn't demonstrate that same level of
drive and aptitude with regards hitting
targets and a need for achievement
whatever it might be you know Bob was
particularly gritty and he could bounce
back from disappointment really really
quick quickly whereas
um Peter didn't have that same bounce
back ability so I think you can start to
make some really good assumptions with
regards to what those key traits are
early on and then as you grow and as the
business gets bigger I think you can
start to be more scientific with it and
you can really start to effectively
grade and assess a larger amount of
people which will give you much more
consistency with regards to those those
things that I've just been describing so
we know in our business that people who
hit a Gia above a certain level
us more more likely to be successful
than people who come in below that level
now that doesn't mean that people who
come in below a certain level aren't
necessarily going to be successful in
recruitment far from it but the key is
to be able to make decisions which are
loaded in your favor from a hiring
perspective from my in my opinion so
again it's about taking that initial
information even if it's just three or
four people that you can start to make
some assumptions based on you can look
at that success and failure make sure
that you're defining what those
characteristics or those traits are that
you've identified lead to either success
or failure be really really clear on
that build yourself a scorecard which
um it is those things
then I think the key is to be able to
define those characteristics and also
build an interview structure which is
aligned to those characteristics so I
always find it quite interesting when
you look at people who are going through
the interview process or interviewing
for their their company they've got
they've got an understanding of what it
is they're looking for but then they
don't actually align their the structure
of the interview and the questions that
they ask to identifying those exact
characteristics and that's weird right
so you have a defined criteria but you
don't then actually align the assessment
process to that criteria so literally
every question you ask in the interview
process should probably in one way or
another be geared towards defining at
least one of those attributes that
you're looking to identify
um
and then
at the end of that process I think it's
about regular review so going back to
what I said earlier I think the context
is really important who you're selling
to where you're selling and the stage of
growth you're about as a business
the same type of recruiter who is
successful working for one of the big
corporate goliaths
possibly they could be the best biller
out of a thousand recruiters but put
them in a startup environment where they
don't have that straight same
infrastructure they don't have that same
ability to follow a a clearly mapped out
an optimal process they don't have
training on every single aspect of the
process whatever it might be best
practice that person might not be
successful so again as your business
grows I think it's really important not
this isn't just a one and done job you
have to regularly review this stuff and
make sure that you're reviewing it on a
quarterly maybe a biannual basis to
ensure you know the people that are
coming through the business that are
being successful is it because of the
criteria that we've identified
previously is there anything we should
be looking to remove or ADD and vice
versa you know it's a big responsibility
when someone doesn't work out why didn't
why didn't these people work out did
they fit the criteria was it a selection
mistake was it our fault or was it it's
always your fault but was it also maybe
that we didn't identify something that
they didn't have or something that they
did have that we need to take into
account so I feel like I've been talking
for a long time there but hopefully that
adds some some color to the answer
no no I think that's really interesting
I think we've all heard that sentence
where people have gone if only I had
five more Alex Elliots do you know what
I mean so actually the insight there is
the evidence is your people
um and really doing the the work of
understanding yeah why is it that
they're successful so I think I think I
think that's a really great insight
I guess where I wanted to start Alex
you've been doing a really good job on
on the LinkedIn front
uh I think it's fair to say consistently
sharing I think putting out some some
really good content and the first
question I had I guess in hindsight and
I don't know I'm sure you continue to
think about this and and the relevant
context but you you did you did two
posts around like the the 25 of the most
important lessons I learned Building 100
million pound Revenue business and I
guess where I wanted to start I'm not
going to get you to talk through each
20th and uh each 25 lesson but I wanted
to just start with like look looking
back what what would you say if we were
to make it to distill it down to some
principles I don't know how many
principles they're gonna be but like
what what were the principles do you do
you believe looking back that really
enabled you and John to successfully
scale that recruitment business because
a lot of people don't one sell their
recruitment business and a lot of people
don't scale their recruitment business
and and get to that stage so I guess
looking back what would you say were
some of the principles do you think of
of doing that
if you have to boil it down look I'd
suggest there's probably there's
probably four key barriers to let
looking at that question and actually
saying all right well instead of
answering what are the principles the
scaling a recruitment business for Me
Maybe the starting point is to identify
what are the barriers to scaling
business and then if you identify what
those barriers are you can then look at
the other side of that and say all right
well how do we not do those things or
how do we remove those barriers so I
think there's there's four key things
that you have to focus in on which are
your your your critical barriers to
growth and and these aren't in any
particular order but leadership number
one thing that you need to be able to do
is develop leaders in your business so
um I say the number one thing I say no
no none of these four things are in any
particular order but if you can't
develop leaders in a recruitment
business one of the things that I
sometimes see recruitment leaders get a
bit wrong is they think scaling a
recruitment business is about hiring
lots of great recruiters
and I don't actually think that's quite
right for me the the number one
fundamental thing is that you have to be
able to hire lots and lots of great
recruiters
and and train and develop and retain
those guys but the critical piece in
that though is that you have to be able
to turn or convert a high enough
proportion of those recruiters into your
future leaders
if you can't do that your business won't
scale so first and foremost you have to
be able to identify attracts and bring
into the business either experienced
leaders which is tough unless you know
them already because that that you know
from my experience that's a really
challenging thing to do or you have to
be able to bring in people at the very
beginning of their career give them the
skills and ability to be able to become
really successful recruiters and then
the ones that are suited to and aligned
with leadership you need to be able to
convert a high enough proportion of into
leaders I think we did that pretty well
at liquid so first and foremost I think
we were quite good bringing people in
and putting them through that conveyor
belt where they went through a constant
Learning and Development program up to
their skills and became you know we had
we have people in their mid-20s running
40 50 person you know divisions of the
business multi-million pounds huge
profitability wise units of the business
so I think we were quite good at
developing leaders
the second thing that I'd say really
really critical is scalable
infrastructure and if you can't put in
place if you can't identify in your
business what the Core Business
processes are and then put in place
continually reviewed the optimal working
process for all aspects of your business
I think it's going to be really really
tough to scale because you you I think
one of my favorite
I think it's from a book called The
e-myth and and in that they what's the
chap say he says um the processes run
the business and the people run the
processes and that always stuck with me
because I think that's really really
true if you look at what business is
business is about having a really good
process so if you can't put scalable
infrastructure and good processes into
your business I think you're going to
reach a point where you don't grow
anymore and again I think we were good
at that liquid so we built really really
good infrastructure
um the third thing would be new business
if you knew profitable business if you
can't continually win profitable
business whether from existing accounts
by Landing expanding accounts or by
winning new business and then turning
That Into You Know Wales and profitable
accounts you're not going to be able to
scale your business because the business
is going to starve and lastly cash flow
the fourth thing I'd say that you've got
to be really really good at is cash flow
if you can't
if you can't win enough profitable
business where you've got strong enough
cash flow to be able to continually
invest in the first three three things
that I described
um you're not going to be able to
reinvest back into the business to grow
aggressively enough to keep scaling so I
think if you look at those four things
we were pretty good at those four things
at liquids and then if you look at those
and then you put them onto the the other
side of the coin they're probably a good
starting point to say well how do I
ensure these barriers don't don't happen
and if you're doing that you're probably
setting yourself up pretty well to be
able to scale
I love that yeah you did that I had that
yeah you did that as a as a post as well
didn't you so yeah I love that
uh I think I guess what I wanted to ask
him
then my grandpa knows it is exactly no
it's exactly how you break it down is
exactly how you broke it down
I guess what what would be really
interesting to hear your thoughts on
then you you've mentioned the word
infrastructure a number of times
scalable infrastructure
um what what would you say and and we
can we'll definitely go on to strive on
this because you might have some some
perspective from from uh being part of
that business as well but really curious
at liquid what would you let's say we
yeah like you said we've got that
conveyor belt of taking people on that
leadership Journey for the people that
want it and and yeah able to upskill
them and create those leaders but what
would you say was the the most impact
there may not be but what would you say
is the most important hire of all when
it comes to really helping the business
scale for example an Ops Director people
manager sales director I don't know that
maybe looking back you're like you know
what that was so critical to helping us
get to the next stage I don't know if
anything comes up for you on that
I think early on you you need someone to
manage your finances that's really
really important do not try and manage
your own finances would be my advice we
tried to do that John and I tried to do
that early on and we just made a
complete and utter mess of it we
outsourced it
um obviously but but we made an absolute
mess of it and by the time Helen our our
eventual FB came into the business she
had quite a mess to clear up basically
because we were just rubbish so I think
making sure that you've got an expert
managing your Finance is really
important but again I think look at
strive as the example we we hire we have
a lady called Mackenzie who is our ops
manager and
that the challenge you've got in
recruitment businesses is it's the sales
people it's the recruiters you get all
the glory and it's often the people in
the background who are just as if not
even more important to the growth of
that business and the people on the
front line and the trenches every day
who get all of the glory when you know
the the deals come in
um McKenzie is absolutely exceptional
she is the glue that binds the business
together operationally she's the doer
who when you've got entrepreneurial
types they aren't always necessarily
myself included they're not natural
finishers they're not the people that
they met there may be good ideas people
they may be good at creating they're
quite visionary
but maybe they're not the people who can
actually follow through and actually
execute on things and I think someone
like MacKenzie who brings an operational
mindset instead of a sales mindset she
brings structure and process
she brings organization and she brings
executions to the table she has been an
absolute game changer for us as a
business and we wouldn't be where we are
now
we're we're still reasonably small right
so we're 25 heads something like that
but what we've spent this last couple of
years doing is really putting in those
things that I've described to you so
effectively where we're
within a position where we can start to
really really aggressively scale and
we've put in place or we're currently in
the process of putting in place all of
that infrastructure and platform which
most businesses at 20 to 25 heads
they're not even close to doing so what
we've done is we've kind of looked at it
and said all right well let's look at
140 personal recruitment business and
which was Liquid by the time I exited
what were the the business processes in
the infrastructure that we had in place
at the the point of exit let's within
reason put as much of that in place as
early as possible in strive so that
instead of figuring it out and doing it
as we go along we just have it all there
ready to go we wouldn't have been able
to do that without Mackenzie so again a
bit of a long-winded answer but you know
just big up to Mackenzie here if she
doesn't um say thank you after this to
me for for shouting her out so
proactively I will be I'm horrified but
no she's amazing and she would be a
perfect example get an option manager in
early and if they're good they'll be a
game changer for you
so I think what what might be helpful
then because I did I did want to ask you
this
um later on but I think that this would
be a good time to ask it so you said
there
you wanted to yeah ultimately build the
processes and the infrastructure and the
scalability of 140 person company before
your way yeah before you even arrive at
that destination so could you if you're
happy to I think this would be really
helpful for small grown recruitment
entrepreneurs who have yeah that
business like what does the org chart
look like then you just mentioned
McKenzie because I think if I was to
speak to emotional recruiting
entrepreneurs and I say right what does
your business look like they might have
they'll go I'm the founder of the
business are still involved in in
um yeah winning some clients dealing
with some existed relationships I might
help drive performance and then I might
have one to three leaders that also do
some billing and then they have I have
people under them I wouldn't be
surprised if typically it looks like
that some of these companies might have
an office manager or someone like that
in in the in that role but you said you
really worked hard on this and you've
taken your lessons from liquid what does
that all chart look like then
foreign
Devil's Advocate and push back a little
bit by org chart do you mean the
responsibilities of like the senior
leadership team what they themselves are
doing that kind of where you're going
with that
no I guess what I'm trying to just to
make it really easy for people you said
how important that is and I guess I'm
trying to think about if I'm listening
to this what would be really helpful so
I guess what I was just hoping you would
share is if I was to look at the strive
business today of all this work that you
put in like
who more about more about the the people
in different seats so if I was to look
at the business today I might have Adam
Adam and Harrison at the top of the
founder of the business then I've got an
Ops person then we've got four leaders
and then we've got to get what I mean I
think people just be interested on them
on 2025 business what does that actually
look like where it can give me some
ideas on how I can actually start
thinking about how I want my business to
be structured I think the
responsibilities is a whole different
question
I think the the structure is going to be
a little bit dependent again on context
so I think the answer like always is it
depends a little bit I I guess the key
thing you've got to decide early on from
an organizational perspective is you
said it yourself you'll often have at
the beginning or an early stage business
you'll have maybe the the MD at the top
and the MD is basically still a
Rainmaker they are still heavily
involved in the sales side of the
business so I think from an
organizational perspective one of the
first decisions you've got to make is at
what points do certain people step away
from the day-to-day sales aspect of the
business
and they stop working in the business
and they have to start working on the
business so using strive as the example
Adam is the managing director he works
very very closely with MacKenzie who's
our operations manager and Adam does not
have that's not quite Fair he still is
involved in some of our senior level
relationships with VCS etc etc but
typically Adam is not involved in the
day-to-day running of the business
Beyond strategic and tactical
implementation and management on the
other side of that you've got Harrison
who's our Global sales director Harrison
is that guy who who housing Kicks Down
doors that you shouldn't be able to kick
down
he's that guy he's he just finds a way
somehow to win clients and win business
that he shouldn't be able to win to be
quite Frank so he's your natural he's
just your hyper-driven competitive
winner who finds business so he's super
super involved in the business on a
day-to-day perspective from a new logo
perspective below those guys and look
we've got a hyper flat management
structure as well just to put that out
there we're a small business so I don't
think you should have a particularly
um
you shouldn't have a particularly
detailed org chart at this point right
we've then got
um leaders
who are either director level or mid
manager level depending upon their
experience and their seniority but again
it's completely pretty flat management
um org charts so those guys will then
have management responsibility and
Leadership responsibility so does that
answer your question I'm not entirely
sure and then you know I support houses
no it does yeah the FD sort of supports
um Helen who was RFD at liquid is our
you know it manages all of our finances
that strive so again it's great that
we've got that Finance Financial
expertise I don't know if that answers
your your question
now it does I think I'll definitely get
people thinking on like what they can
aim for because I think yeah you've
spoken a lot about the infrastructure
and and the importance of that so I
think that yeah that would just be
helpful for people on yeah
you have to make a decision about when
you're going to take a hit on your
short-term profitability that that's
bottom line the decision you've got to
make so typically if you start up a
recruitment business it's because you've
been really successful as recruiting
historically therefore when you start
that business for a considerable time
you're going to be you're going to be
one of the the principal earners that
bring money into that business if
there's two of you it gets to a point
where probably one of you says right
now's the time for me to step away from
day-to-day billing and for me to stop
working in the business and start
working on the business so I guess you
know that that's the key fundamental
decision and that is going to have an
impact upon short-term profitability of
course it is but that I guess also about
understanding what your long-term goal
and aspirations are if it's just to have
a small recruitment business and
maximize profitability in the short
medium and long you know in the short
term don't do that if your long-term
objective is to really scale and build
something of size
you're going to have to make that
decision at some point and probably a
lot of recruitment companies they they
don't make that decision or they make it
too late
they make it later than they should do
so I guess something that I always hear
as well that I yeah again isn't very
evidence or scientific is when to hire
like obviously you scaling
um liquid and then obviously actually
enrolled in Australia have you I don't
know have you have you got any thoughts
on more of an Evidence science-based
approach on hiring triggers and when
it's gonna be yeah when you're going to
be more when you're going to feel more
confident hiring I don't know yeah is it
do you have anything on that out of
interest that you've I don't know maybe
created a bit of a science behind
uh look the typical like the accountants
out there will tell you once you get to
a certain level of profit per head
across your business that's the trigger
to hire some more people
um okay we never looked at it that way
to be honest we didn't so I I think
there's value in looking at it like that
and I think that's one good metric to
look at because the reality is if you're
not if you're not already kind of
maximizing the profitability and the
potential of your existing team I don't
think you should be adding more heads
what you actually need to do is focus on
getting your existing team up to really
high standards before you start adding
heads but
we kind of looked at the opportunity we
were really really good at training and
developing people and getting them up to
a required standard reasonably quickly
so we basically looked at our cash flow
we looked at our jobs because at the end
of the day there's no point continuing
to hire if you're not going to be able
to feed the people that are coming into
the business that's if you've got a 180
model if it's a 360 model
is slightly different but we looked at
our cash flow we forecast our
requirements and the opportunity that
there was in the marketplace and and we
just went at it really really
aggressively so my FD would probably be
horrified to hear me describing it like
that because she'd be a lot more
analytical and she'd want to have some
specific
specific numbers around PPH which she'd
like us to hit on a for a quarterly
basis or for two two running quarters
something like that
genuinely that was something we weren't
quite a scientific on we looked at it
holistically and we said you know
there's the opportunity here to grow by
X and we're just going to maximize our
growth potential and we were quite good
at balancing the opportunity versus
bringing people in below by looking
across a number of different factors
interesting
uh so so help me out here then so with
you
um Exton liquid what what did that deal
look like in terms of like when it was
done was it straight away you and John
could leave the business was an earn out
period because I I just want to ask some
questions around the latter end of of
that we were really um we were really
fortunate with the buyer that we
we quickly came to the agreement terms
of the deal we could relieve very
quickly
so there wasn't a learn out for us we
the reality was we built a business
which wasn't it wasn't Reliant upon us
anymore and I think if you're going to
build something which you can exit from
you have to build a business which runs
without you and we had an amazing board
we had an amazing senior in mid-level
management team
we the the organization that bought us
were very experienced within the sectors
not necessarily the vertical and the
sector that we worked in but
complementary verticals and
complementary sectors within the
healthcare space so they already had a
lot of knowledge of our of our Market in
general and principle and they also had
someone that could come in
um and oversee things who had a good
understanding of that Marketplace but
look we had a managing director we had a
finance director we had an Ops director
and we had a senior leadership team on
the sales side who basically ran that
business so it enabled us to be able to
leave really quickly
um we didn't have an urn out I think
from selling the business to actually
leaving the business was about three
months and then you know we we got the
rest of our money about a year later but
that wasn't based around an earn out I
don't think at the time
so a lot of people will think this and
and probably want to ask like did that
sell meet your expectations
um
yeah
so I I I don't think it was a sale which
is is is the really interesting bit the
interesting bit came after was well I'm
sure for other people the interesting
bit is the actual sales so look we
we were fortunate enough to create a
situation and we had lots of luck along
the way where we you know we we made a
we we did very well out of selling the
business obviously because we wouldn't
have done that otherwise but we did it
for the right reasons as well because
the reality is while you've got owner
Founders in place that's always going to
there's always going to be a bit of a
glass ceiling when you've got the owner
Founders sitting there taking up the
most senior positions within the
business so yeah we we we obviously did
very well out of it but at the same time
so did the people that came through
because you know some of the people earn
who some of the senior people they earn
life-changing amounts of money from us
selling that business but as well as
that
are the the managing director of that
company is a great guy he really really
you know really good guy and very smart
individual he's the managing director of
that company now he started off as a
trainee
every single one of our sales directors
in that business started off as trainees
every single one of our associate
directors in that business started off
as trainees every single one of our
sales managers and team leaders you know
the entire business was based around
hiring super talented individuals who
came in early in on in their career and
over the course of that 10 years really
really established themselves in their
in their Market
um and and did really special things for
themselves so I think the the exit was
really valuable for lots of people not
just myself and John the interesting bit
came afterwards I think when you try and
figure out what you're going to do after
that but maybe that's that's a
conversation topic for another day
yeah because I think a lot yeah I think
that is I've spoken to
a couple of people I mean yeah I was
listening to one of the interviews and
it sounded like one of the first things
you did was by your parents a villa in
Spain
I did yeah that's very true actually
that was quite a proud moment
because yeah I think a lot of people are
yeah just I spoke to a couple of people
that have experienced moments like that
and uh obviously I think I don't know
from the people that I've spoken to Alex
you're the way that it worked for you
guys sounded um a bit unique because
that's what a number of questions when I
reached out to people about interviewing
people like you in the journey that
you've been on they're asking questions
around the earn out and what it was like
to report to people that yeah ultimately
maybe now own the business and those
types of things like that can be really
difficult where you get millions and
millions of pounds into your bank
account and then you go back to your
office the following day and you're like
right we like I have to carry on
crack on and that that can be obviously
a difficult
it's really difficult like there's no
it's a high Asian proverb behind the
mountains there are mountains and I
think that you you can you can I really
like that and I think it's true for lots
of different things in life but I think
John I'm speaking on behalf of John here
but I'm pretty sure John would say the
exactly I know John would say the same
thing I don't think we thought enough
about what mountain was behind that
particular Mountain so I think we were
so far focused on exiting that business
we worked incredibly hard for 10 years
we put our heart our our heart and our
soul you know into into making a dent in
the universe with that company which we
did do which was amazing I don't think
we enjoyed the journey as much as we
should have done because I think we were
too focused on the end result so I think
that's a really important thing for
people to think about try and enjoy the
journey despite the fact that it's it's
an incredibly hard journey at times I
think it's really important to to try
and take a step back and enjoy it a
little bit as well because I don't think
we did that enough and then when we did
get to the end of it
I think there was a bit of a feeling of
like oh wow I hadn't really thought
about this in a lot of detail what do I
do now so that I think they call it is
it Olympic gold syndrome where yeah
after yeah people go on look I don't
know there's so many different examples
in athletics or sport isn't it there are
people yet reach the absolute pinnacle
and then actually the period after that
is the really tough bit and I think you
know again I'm speaking on behalf of
John here but I think both of us found
that for a year or so afterwards I don't
think we've probably enjoyed that year
After exiting the business as much as we
expected to to be quite Frank because we
probably hadn't thought enough about
what comes next
now I appreciate you sharing that so I
guess I know this is one of the most
common questions you always get asked on
I make sure I I ask it at this stage
uh and then I have a number of different
things that I want to ask you a bit more
about strive so I think you said to me
right the probably the number one
question you always have people ask you
is like how how does a recruitment
business get valued
um so what why didn't you why don't you
give us some education on that Alex and
like yeah the typical things that you
speak to people about and I know there's
you also shared around sometimes what
people lose sight of but yeah what if
I'm listening to this and I do have
Ambitions to sell or at least achieve
some sort of exit if that's for an MBO
maybe a different way but yeah thinking
about my business in the future is
something that I do want to exit and
Achieve that business to them like how
is it that you found in your on your
journey
how how recruitment this is a typically
valued and what what these types of
companies may look at
sure I should have thought about this in
advance so I I'm not particularly like
this isn't particularly going to be a
structured answer but
some of the key aspects to think about I
think
what one of the things that I find
people maybe don't have as much one
thing that would be good for people to
know you have to reach but when people
are looking to buy your recruitment
business they're not buying what your
business has done historically what
they're doing is they're buying your
future profits so first and foremost
they're buying you future profits not
what you've done historically
you have to reach a certain level of
scale
from a profitability perspective where
you're going to be able to interest
enough people
to look at and be interested in buying
your business to to justify a large
enough multiple which would make it
probably worthwhile for you to sell that
business
so just to be a little bit more
definitive with that I would suggest to
you that unless you can reach 3 million
ebitda
your book your business probably isn't
going to be worth what you think it is
or what you would like it to be from a
multiple perspective and again without
going into lots of lots of detail around
that I think that's important for people
to understand because there's a lot of
people out there who have got great
recruitment businesses but the reality
is they're just not at the sort of scale
that would
um attract a large enough number of
buyers to be interested who would then
create the competition amongst
themselves to be able to drive up the
multiple to sell that business
evaluation which you probably think your
business is worth and I would suggest
your starting point is about 3 million
and just quickly on that yeah just
quicker than Alex I can just like just
so yeah ebitda would just like simple
even though
if you think about your operating profit
ebitda is effectively it's an accounting
principle where accountants can look at
all businesses regardless of the
industry or the sector they work in and
operating profit might be quite
different based upon the different
Industries you're in because you have
depreciation for instance of machinery
and stuff like that so that can make a
massive difference in some Industries
compared to recruitment that's not an
issue because the reality is you don't
have lots of equipment which is
depreciating in value but effectively
it's it's a slightly different way of
looking at operating profit
okay nice love that so this is um
industries from an accounting
perspective
yeah so the insight there is that that's
probably the the one thing that you
really want to look at but yeah that's
the really one thing that you want to
focus on I think you shared with me your
recruitment business so I think from a
financial Target perspective that has to
be your minimum Benchmark that you're
aiming to achieve
um yeah that's really interesting that
that's kind of like a fundamental
starting point I think sometimes people
might um might not be aware of I I heard
someone told me something recently that
I thought was really cool and what was
it so what they said was and I'm not
going to say who said this because it's
second-hand information but someone
who's very experienced within the m a
space Zed at three million you can take
your business to Market and there will
be in people interested in in looking at
it and potentially buying your business
at five million you'll have people
knocking on your door to talk to you
about your business and at 10 million
you'll have people queuing around the
street to come and basically buy your
company so from a recruitment
perspective so those are big big numbers
but again I just think it's really
important to be clear with people that
if your business is is generating a half
a million a million in ebitda the truth
is it's probably not going to be able to
attract enough people unless there's a
real strategic value in the vertical
that you work in for the potential
purchaser or maybe the territory that
you you have unless there's a really
really compelling strategic value for a
purchaser then you're probably just not
going to be big enough to be able to
sell that company as I say at a multiple
that makes it you're worthwhile makes it
worthwhile for you worthwhile
yeah
um
going back to that previous point so
once you've got that understanding of
what you need to achieve from a
financial perspective the reality is
they're buying future profits so forget
what the company's done historically
what they're doing is they're looking at
those existing profits and they're
saying what's the potential to grow
these profits further so if we're doing
three million now can we be doing 5
million in three years time in
profitability
and what are the risks to that
so if you think about that what are the
things which are going to mean that this
company continues growing at the sort of
growth rate that it has been growing at
because what they don't want to do is
buy a business at 3 million ebitda
that's still doing three million ebitd
Darwin three five years time they want
to buy a growth opportunity where they
can make additional income moving
forward so what are the things that you
need to put in place to justify that and
demonstrate that you're in a gross
market and that the business plan
justifies the fact that the companies
can continue growing rather than the
fact that you've tapped out and you're
selling at the top of the market the
other side of that coin is the risk
involved with that so client
concentration if 50 of your business
comes from three clients that is a huge
risk
if you don't have scale from a
consultant perspective and your top
three billers contribute I don't know 30
40 of your total income that's a huge
risk to a potential purchaser if you are
too heavily involved in making strategic
as the leadership team if you as the
owner and you're going to be leaving if
you are too involved in the business
ensuring its ongoing success that's
going to be a huge risk to the potential
purchaser
um
if the market is changing if the
Dynamics of the marketplace are changing
and the market potentially isn't going
to continue growing or there isn't going
to be the same supply and demand
Dynamics or maybe the financials are
changing within the space and margins
are coming down that's a huge risk the
ongoing profitability and growth of that
business so
I think it's a case of weighing up how
how can we how can we reassure ourselves
as a potential purchaser that that
existing level of profitability is going
to continue growing and what are the
things that we also need to look at from
a risk perspective on the other side of
that coin which are the potential
dangers
um
so so that that's something else that
maybe the purchases are looking at and
again that to be frank I've done this
once right I sold one recruitment
business so it's not like I'm an expert
but this is what I've taken from the
process that I went through locks
massive so you have to get lucky and
people again don't necessarily want to
hear that but the truth is I think
anyone who's successfully exited a
recruitment business at scale they know
there was a large element of luck
involved in that market timing is so
important
if you get unlucky if Bob has got the
exact same business as Jane but Bob is
at the right is in the right time in the
market from an economic growth
perspective compared to Jane Bob sells
his business Jane doesn't it doesn't
mean Jane's business wasn't just as good
as Bob's
he just got lucky I don't know why I'm
going with Bob and Jane but I can't
remember how to do these people are I've
just randomly picked up Bob and Jane
those two businesses are just as good as
each other the reality is one got lucky
with Market timing and the other one
didn't so I think that's really
important
um and and that luck piece again I think
it's
how much value are you to a purchaser
from a strategic perspective based upon
their existing business and what you can
offer them surely Beyond just like
potential profitability into the future
I think that's really really important
as well
um and there's an element of luck with
that you know you sometimes you get
lucky because you're the right type of
company in the right place at the right
time
for that particular organization that's
looking for a company like you so yeah
there's luck involved which
um which is is super important
certainly so many great insights in
there I guess look as we come to the end
here then like
you've like you said uh thinking about
strive you've done obviously bachelor's
four critical barriers I know you've
done some loads of really good work
around the sort of leadership and exec
program that you've built or continue to
build you've got this scalable
infrastructure or platform that strives
so I guess let's just sort of end on
like so now now you've got that what is
it now that you really keep a close on
is it just then the profitable new
business or is it more about Riot how
can we continue to review the types of
people that are successful in our
organization and make sure we continue
to keep those standards and hire more of
those people how can we continue to get
the most out of our teams and and
continue to win that new business and is
that they're the simple things that we
just need to focus on now if we've got
that infrastructure if we've got that
that leadership program and the
leadership team in place as well what
what's like yeah the the things that are
now top of mind going into this next
chapter and exciting chapter with strive
you have to keep turning the flywheel so
if you heard that analogy by Jim Collins
we're really good analogy right so once
you've got everything working the key at
that point is about execution and
optimization so I think it's really
really important to understand the
the infrastructure or the the um the
foundations you have to put in place to
be able to go get a business to the
point where you can start to scale
really really aggressively once you've
got those foundations in place which
we've we've been doing at strive
um for for a couple of years now it
starts to get really really exciting I
think
you know I do want to like I do want to
talk about strive here because I've kind
of seen this movie before because I saw
it yeah
I didn't necessarily know it at the time
but I've seen this movie before and I
Know How It Ends and
you know that might sound a bit boring
but the ending's really really good
um and the journey that you go through
to get to that ending is absolutely
amazing I think one of the things that
we did at liquid was we we wanted to
make a dent in the universe and at the
beginning we were just 20 people in a
room that said let's become the best in
the world at what we do
and that was quite compelling for us
because we said right there's some
established players in this place we're
going to take on we're just this small
recruitment Company in Manchester and
back then all of our competitors were
based in London
they were big they'd been around for a
long time they were really really
established and what we did was we were
just 20 people and we sat in a room and
said right we are going to make a dent
in this universe and we're going to
become the market leader within 10 years
we're going to take on and beat every
single one of those established players
in this space and we're going to make a
dent in the universe and at the end of
this journey we're going to be able to
say that we took this business from
nothing effectively to being the very
very best in the world at what we do
we're in exactly that same place at this
moment in time at strive and that's why
I'm so Keen to you know build my profile
online and maybe get a bit of
recognition for what the guys at striver
doing because it's a really congested
crowded Market at the moment and
there's so many recruitment companies
out there that look and sound the same
but they're not the same some company
and I'm not that that's not in any way
being critical of other recruitment
companies far from it but I've seen this
movie before I know where we go from
here and it's such an except such an
exciting time to get in on the ground
level in a business like this because
we're about to go through that hyper
growth stage
so I'm really really Keen to sort of
shout from the the raft of the the
rafters whatever that saying is and
really sort of
describe to people what that opportunity
is and hopefully get them as excited as
we are about where we're going as an
organization
you notice how I didn't actually answer
your questions
[Music]
that's fine well I think I think that's
uh
a great place to end I think look so
many insights in there absolutely love
your energy and passion for the
recruitment industry and yeah like super
excited to yeah continue to see outside
looking in what what you guys achieve at
strive but yeah thank you so much for
for joining me
I really enjoy it it feels like it's
been five minutes I've just been talking
solid for an hour so you can rest now
you don't have to put up with me anymore
but no thank you I've really enjoyed it
and I love what you're doing the gem so
thank you